as part of president biden's trip to
georgia he traveled to the headquarters
of the centers for disease control and
prevention in atlanta
his visit coincided with the cdc issuing
new relaxed coveted guidelines for
social distancing
in classrooms in an effort to get more
schools reopened around the country
on friday the president also met his
goal of getting 100 million coronavirus
vaccines
administered in his first 100 days in
office
more than a month ahead of schedule to
date more than 77 million americans have
received
at least one dose of the vaccine with 41
million now fully vaccinated
the pace of the vaccine rollout is also
ramping up
to an average of about two and a half
million a day
but health experts are warning of some
hot spots potentially ticking up
natalie brand has more from the white
house
this is a war and you are the front line
troops
president biden and vice president
harris praised cdc staffers on the same
day the administration reached a key
milestone
ahead of schedule we just met my goal of
administering
100 million shots before my first 100
days in office
we did it about 60 days but the
country's top health experts
acknowledged the challenges ahead
including an
uptick in new cases partly due to the
new covid variants
it has been detected in 50 jurisdictions
in the united states
and likely accounts now for about 20
to 30 percent of the infections in this
country
and that number is growing
a concern for some educators as the cdc
issues new guidance for schools to get
students back into the classroom
now recommending math students remain
just three feet apart
instead of six with the exception of
those in middle and high schools
in areas with high coveted transmission
we are following the science and we have
done the science
and we've seen the science to make to
ensure that this is safe
for those schools the studies thus far
on you know on distancing have been
pretty muddled
the american federation of teachers
president randy weingarten says the
union is reserving judgment for now
why not trust the cdc's guidance we have
to figure out
in all these schools right now which
have been
set up for six feet physical distancing
how this is going to work
and the updated cdc guidance says that
six feet distancing
still should be maintained between
adults that's teachers and staffers and
then adults and children
and at times when mass cannot be worn
and the cdc notes it's really up to
schools
in collaboration with state and local
health officials
to determine how to implement its
considerations and to what extent
michelle
natalie thank you so much